are you under a thousand subscribers and
racking your brain for video ideas well
in this episode and QA of the think
marketing show I'm gonna be sharing with
you the one video idea that you need to
create next on your channel but if we're
just meeting my name is Heather Torres
and I'm the host here of the think
marketing podcast I'm a member of the
think media team and I am so fired up
and excited to be joining you today and
let's just jump right into the tip and
then we will be getting into some Q&A
we're gonna be bringing you on camera if
you want to join us for a quick Q&A
session with myself with Tony and
Melissa from the think media team but
let's get right into the video that you
need to create next the video I want you
to create is called a vs. video well
what's a versus video Heather let me
show you here I think media we do a ton
of vs. videos you can check out our
channel at think media and you'll see we
do things like camcorder vs. DSLR you'll
see mirrorless vs. DSLR best shotgun
microphones for YouTube now
why is important to do a vs. video well
because when someone is typing in two
different things they might be in a
buying decision think about that the
reason that we do this camera versus
this camera is because it gets people to
the point of an answer to them
purchasing a product and if you're set
up with affiliate marketing or you're
set up with a brand this is how you get
money for the mission it's so critical
to be thinking this way because rather
than just doing a tips video or a hacks
video or something like that
this actually allows you to get the
answer to their question now does this
work in other niches absolutely let me
show you this is my home school channel
the home school house and I did a video
called homeschooling versus public
schooling this is a versus video again
and it's helping you to see the
difference between the two now in here I
do have affiliate marketing inside of
there where I'm showing people the
different types of curriculum and ways
that they can get started with
homeschooling how about vegan
versus vegetarian well this channel
right here they did this video four
years ago and guess what in their
description they have affiliate
marketing links are you seeing the value
of this I also just purchased a RV and I
watched so many of these videos RV vs.
travel trailer this is for every niche
there's probably two products that you
have that people are that people are
comparing now what if you don't know
everything about both of the products
well check out this channel kids Friday
podcasts guess what they did they went
to Costco and they wanted to buy a TV
and they actually just asked the Costco
employee for the difference between the
Vizio versus the Samsung 4k are you
seeing the value of this you can
actually just go to the experts and ask
them but title your video as a versus
video let me know in the chat or in the
comments section below have you already
done your vs. video and what video was
it how about this if you're in the
financial space
what about apps that you can do well
this channel right here marble jar
channel she reviewed three different
apps and guess what she has affiliate
links to all of those apps inside of her
description you seen the value of this
now what about gardening here's a great
one that we found raised beds versus
in-ground beds you'll see that there are
links to this person's website where
they go deeper into online courses that
are explaining how to do different
gardening techniques so it doesn't
necessarily have to be that you're
selling one of the products in the vs.
video but you could be answering the
question for that person that leads them
to your world and I was just talking to
Tony here on the think media team and
him and his wife they have a Cooking
Channel and his wife was at the store
buying some really high-end cookware and
I said well I wonder if there's a video
about that and what did she guess all
clad stainless versus Calphalon
Calphalon nasi I can't even cook I don't
even know what this is but they do and
they made a versus video in the
description of this video you could be
leading people to purchasing these
high-end cookware
pieces are you seeing the value out of
this here's my challenge to you think
marketing I want you to make your next
verses video if you're under a thousand
subscribers this is a way to polarize
yourself into the YouTube algorithm this
is a way for you to get noticed by
someone who is actually interested in
that thing rather than you making a
video about your day or doing a tips
video this is a way that you can
actually get your material in front of
the right people well I hope that helps
you I hope that brought value to you and
I want to bring on Tony from the think
media team Tony verses videos they're so
important aren't they they're so
important and it's it is really helping
people solve a real problem in your
really self qualifying that you were
before they even check in and watch your
video they're like I'm struggling with
this problem you're here like the whites
the with the white knight coming in and
going I have an answer for you so it's
so important yes I love that in Melissa
what's great is this really can be in
any niche right we've seen a lot of our
students inside a video ranking Academy
these people are able to do verses
videos and it's so important to do it
under a thousand subscribers right yes
absolutely and one of the common
questions we get is about vlogging and
you can absolutely do this I just was
talking something in the chat you can
absolutely do this with vlogging are you
if you're vlogging within a specific
niche come take it within your video
where you're doing your vlog and compare
two things and make your videos title
this versus that and it's it's something
that can be applied across like you
mentioned Heather all these different
channel niches yeah I'm so excited to
see in the comments section below when
you've done your verses video make sure
to leave it in the comments so that we
can go over and check it out here from
the think marketing podcast well I think
it's time Mel to get into the QA but
this episode is actually brought to you
by our online video conference called
grow with video live this is a virtual
experience I am so excited for growth
video live this year you can get your
virtual ticket that brings this
conference right to your living room for
as little as $97 and Melissa we have
some incredible speakers coming this
year to grow its video live don't we yes
we do and if you want to see the full
list
of the speakers and everything that's
included in your ticket you can head to
grow with video live.com but we have
really powerful speakers that are the
leading experts in our industry who are
going to be teaching you about the the
topics you need to know right now in
order to thrive not just survive but
thrive in the current economy that we're
in to take your YouTube channel and your
business to the next level and so we
have some amazing as I mentioned mazing
speed speakers I can't say it enough we
have Pat Flynn Pete Vargas we have a lot
of just powerful women so if you just
head to the site growth video live.com
you can get that full list yeah and you
know there's three things really Melissa
that I think we're grace with here I
think media when it comes to online
conferences the first is strategy right
we are able to help people go from A to
Z we help give them a road map and
there's going to be printable materials
and things that are gonna help them go
from one and to the other when it comes
to understanding their online strategy
the second is the psychology right
Melissa it's so important when you have
to get your mind right you got to get
your grind on right you got to get
yourself in the right state of mind guys
I just recorded I just recorded intros
and outros for a podcast and forgot to
press record I wasted 30 minutes Melissa
actually recording and because of the
techniques that we've done here at think
media that we've helped our students
learn I was able to flip it back on and
just get back on it and do those videos
and the lastest community I mean Melissa
having community is so important
wouldn't you say the like community
really is one of the most important
things and we're doing some I don't know
if we can tell them all the things we're
doing but community is going to be so
epic I grow with video live this year oh
yes it is we value it so much I think
media and harun think marketing it is so
important to be in community with people
who are like-minded people who
understand what you are doing and your
goals and who can support you and who
can share in the struggles and share in
the wins and so that is such a huge part
of growth video live calm and we're
sorry video live versus reading it
and we're really excited to be pulling
in unique elements and unique ways that
we're gonna be able to foster that
community this year and it's gonna be
really fun I think that's just like an
under rated way to describe it it's
gonna be fun it's not gonna just be
beneficial for your channel it's gonna
be really fun to interact with everybody
and and build the community in that way
yeah and I think what's really powerful
and then we were gonna get to some
people Tony's got some people lined up
backstage right now to come on what's so
incredibly powerful about this year's
growth video live experience is you can
experience it anywhere in the world
right like usually it's in Las Vegas but
this year we brought it online so that
you can experience it in your living
room like on your flat-screen TV or on
your laptop or on your phone we're gonna
have the entire growth video live lineup
coming right to you we're also gonna
have interactive parts right Melissa
where you get to talk with other people
of the community you get to engage and
we're gonna be walking you through how
do you go from where you are now to
where you want to go by using online
video to grow your business and brand so
again you can get your tickets for as
low as $97 right now at growth video
live.com and Melissa we're gonna have
some amazing giveaways like I don't even
want to like say everything but we're
talking like gear and lighting and
courses and I mean some amazing
giveaways are gonna be at groweth video
live this year so grab your tickets all
right Tony
are we ready with some people in the
backstage who is coming on first hey
Aidan how you doing great um just tell
us a little bit about you what your
channel is and then ask us your question
yes so I am actually kind of thing and I
have in the past few days I have figured
out some ways how I can grow my business
just with this and being able to watch
all of your podcasts and think media
think marketing I know I
personal channels as well it's been so
powerful and so the question I have for
you guys is I've been stuck for a little
while on how how can I share my channel
grow those subscribers and viewers and I
can stuck at 40% of people not
subscribed how do I get that up from
about with just besides YouTube in
social media yeah really great question
Aidan I just want to first just applaud
you for being a young entrepreneur man I
am like so proud of you for getting
after it is your focus is your niche
entrepreneurship yes okay great
so you're saying right now you're at us
you're stuck with 40% of your viewing
audience not actually subscribing is
that right exactly okay first I want to
congratulate you because 40 percent is
amazing yeah that is a really good
number usually people are hovering
between 10 and 20 percent of their
viewers actually subscribing to their
content which means Aidan that your
content is super powerful and it's
actually bringing people into your world
so I want to congratulate you first
because that is a huge milestone to have
so I want you to know that that is great
already so and how do we increase that
well one have you made a versus video
Aidan my future good okay good so so
you're already subscribed to think media
so you know that we talked about you
need to make content that your audience
is asking for so if kids are typing in
or if parents are typing in or whoever
you're reaching who's your audience
Aidan is it are you talking to other
young entrepreneurs like yourself yes
actually a little bit right now they
have a hundred ten subscribers
amazing so you're actually doing kind of
like agency work then yes yeah okay
great so I want you to be thinking about
what is your target audiences struggle
what are their pain points what are they
typing in are they typing in
do I grow on YouTube how do I grow on
Instagram are they typing in what books
should I be reading like what are they
struggling with what's the main pain
point and I want you to journal out your
next 50 video ideas okay and then what I
want you to do is I want you to start
thinking about who else has influence
that you can then interview like you
should you should interview um Sean on
your channel like you should reach out
to new influencers and have them help
you growth hack your channel so that's
another way that you can do it but
here's what you need to do you need to
start taking massive action and it's
gonna take time this doesn't happen
instantly it doesn't happen overnight
but as you start doing one video after
another after another when you get to
thirty and fifty and a hundred videos
you can start to look at your analytics
and it's gonna tell you what your
audience likes and I want you to create
community so do you have like a Facebook
group or like do you have some way that
kids can all be talking to each other
like on a whatsapp or something like
that yes I have contact people that we
there's some people that actually join
my Instagram livestream and they started
contacting me through Instagram saying
hey how do I start and like what
powerful way will this work
amazing yeah I want you to create
community I think it'll be really
powerful for you to start a Facebook
group or what's that group or even in
Instagram you can do some private groups
inside of there but I really want you to
get to know your audience I think it's
gonna be really important for you to
know what their struggles are and then I
just want you to crush it okay I want
you to just keep going you're gonna
you're gonna struggle a little bit but
here's the thing you can do this alright
you're already so far and I'll bet
people are watching right now Aiden and
they're like who is this kid I want to
learn from him so I want you to keep
crushing it Melissa any advice for him
yeah I just want to emphasize what
Heather said about focusing on your
audience you are so uniquely positioned
to speak to a particular kind of
entrepreneur somebody especially I think
you're going to be able to reach people
who are your age like you said in such a
unique way you're articulate you are
thinking ahead about what you want to
talk
about what you want to say and that is
going to serve you so well on YouTube
and so as you're looking at what these
other you know YouTube channels are
doing in entrepreneurship think how can
i frame that how can i re make this
video just for my audience maybe how can
I make this more appealing or more fun
or more applicable to people my age and
you're gonna just be able to completely
dominate that I fully believe you guys
have impacted my channel and my business
so much that I've been able to make 15
bucks a month
let's go I love that hey Aidan did you
already get YouTube secrets the book I'm
actually ordering it well hey we're
gonna send it to you okay okay all right
so what I want you to do is you gotta
take a picture of yourself and you got
to send us an email and Tony's gonna
chat with you in the chat in the
backstage and we're gonna get that sent
out to you okay
sounds good to me Aidan we are all about
that so Tony will make everything happen
in the back end okay awesome Wow Melissa
I mean am i I'm like I want to know his
parents I want to know what they did and
how they did it because that is amazing
and you know what I love is that he sees
the value of online business right
Melissa like he just made his money
online and he's just getting started
just like everyone else that's watching
right now and just the powerful impact
that he's gonna have on growing his
business and understanding social media
and helping people it's gonna be amazing
I can't wait to see what happens yeah I
love in the chat where everyone's saying
I want to be Aidan when I grow up so
yeah all want to be Aidan when we guess
you know it's so good alright we ready
for our next we are bringing on learning
and tech hi how's it going good how are
you what an inspiring guy
I'm like I want to be aided that's
wonderful
tell us who you are and what you're all
about so I'm a I'm an old guy but a new
youtuber so so I started with the
pandemic with learning and technology
that's sort of my professional
background so it's a site that helps
teachers and instructors and learner's
better use technology for more effective
and efficient learning so I've gone from
0 to about 356 subscribers in about
three months and I'm up to just about to
hit 65 thousand views so it's really
great starting to get that momentum but
you know one area that I really struggle
with and I'm hoping like to get some
advice on is effective titles for my
videos now you know in the chat I was
saying you know vs vs vs versus spelt
out but but more to the point what makes
a really effective title that can can
hit the search engines yeah really great
question um did you are okay I want it
can you can type in your YouTube channel
Tony you already have that I want to
make sure I can maybe pull it up and see
but really great question how do you
make titles that are going to get views
well one it's all about the topic so the
topic matters so much because if your
topic is not aligned with the title and
people aren't seeing what that looks
like then they actually don't click
through and it actually doesn't get
picked up in the algorithm so what's
really cool about let me show you just
even on here so what would be like a
video that you would create like what's
your next video that you're gonna do so
the next one I'm going to do would be on
using well I'm actually gonna use your
suggestion on the vs I'm going to use
Google classroom versus Microsoft teens
a really great video yes that is
actually look at this I mean it comes up
first here now here's something to learn
so I just type that in and we have for
education see how that changes it and
even this 20/20 so the so maybe it's not
this is the exact title maybe you
actually do this one
new and improved updates or something
like that
or for education because that's where
you're hitting right that's where you're
actually going so this first one right
here now what we want to do is we want
to go over and we want to look at what
people are doing so um this one here you
know we're seeing two K views we're
seeing three K views we're seeing five K
views okay so that is just showing me a
little bit about what people are doing
and then this one okay so let's keep
looking here I wanted to see what the
views are looking at okay so let's go
back and I want to go into um okay let's
go oops I was typing the wrong thing
what did we just say it was Google
classroom versus Microsoft team's
classroom versus Microsoft teams okay
and let's see like just 20/20 let's just
see okay so this is what is showing me
so right away is showing me that the
same people are coming up which means
you can outrank them if you do a great
job at this video first I want you to
watch these videos because I want you to
take note of what did they do well what
could you do different what were they
missing right those are really critical
things when we're making videos we
shouldn't just be making videos in
isolation we should know what we're
competing against right so first things
first is to do that one I'm just looking
here this what this person has five
hundred and ninety subscribers and two
thousand views and he did connecting
your Google classroom to Microsoft teams
for virtual so see how that's even
different he was doing like how to do
that and connect it which is the how-to
video which is really really smart now I
would even think that you could do best
so you could do this Google classroom
2020 - best what would this be called
virtual classroom best virtual classroom
so that even just puts you in a
different category to then rank within
those two different search terms does
that make sense so this is your first
search terms and adding the twenty
twenty I think is actually really
powerful because it's people are
actually looking for it right now they
want to know right now what's the best
one to be doing it to be to be using and
you could do an entire series on this so
it's not about making one versus video
it's about
your next three verses video about like
the mistakes people make the tips for
using or you know the best platforms for
like you could really think about what
you should make what which one of these
would pop off because if one pops off
out of the three then it'll pull the
other two into search as well does that
make sense yeah absolutely awesome so
yeah I use a lot of times people say you
know what software do you use I'm using
right now first off just the Google
search bar next I would actually bring
it into vid IQ and I would see what is
the search possibility I mean like if I
if I make this video and only three
thousand people are searching it well
then I can expect to probably get about
500 to a thousand views on that video so
it's also just realigning I think a lot
of times people want big numbers they
want big things to happen
but it's about every base hit right it's
not about the huge grand slam it's about
every base hit and so while you're
creating this library of content what
happens is your start getting these
comments in you're happening
I just binge watched all of your videos
we get that all the time and that's
actually what you want to happen you
don't necessarily just want one massive
video and then nothing else getting
getting views on it does that make sense
oh yeah exactly so that's how you grow
your channel I'm really inspired by what
you're doing I think that this is a huge
place to be in I would even be doing
things like zoom versus I would do
Google classroom versus every single one
I would do Microsoft teams versus every
single one does that make sense like you
would really rock with that and then the
next tutorials to make are how to use it
so for us here at I think media we're
making videos right now on step by step
how to use stream yard now stream yard
themselves have step by step but we know
how to use the YouTube algorithm to have
those videos come up and be ranked so
they would search stream yard versus
zoom our video would come up they'd
watch that video and then the next video
is how to use it
rights and then they just get sucked in
because minutes matter most on the
YouTube algorithm does that help you out
yeah that helps me out a huge amount oh
you know a lot it's fantastic thank you
know a well that makes me so excited
thank you so much for being a part of
I think marketing show are you
subscribed to the podcast
oh yes I am yes thank you so much thank
you wow that is such a great question I
love how you said I'm going to use the
vs. strategy because that's what matters
right it's like taking what you're
learning and applying it right there and
especially when you're in a niche like
he's in it's so important to answer the
pain points people want to know what is
the difference how do I use it because
right now especially where we are in the
world people are needing information and
you could be on the other side of that
search that's how you grow your online
business that's how you become an
influencer in your space well Tony who
else do we have coming up right now I'm
really excited to see Melissa was that
cool I love verses videos yes and I also
really love that we just had a ton on
first and then then we brought on
another channel and just seeing like the
diversity of like age ranges and the
stage that you're in in your business is
just really powerful I saw a lot of
people that were just so appreciating
that and a chat and I'm stoked to have
so many different people watching think
marketing and starting your own channels
it is so encouraging to see that and
it's motivating for me and I saw a lot
of people saying that like man this is
really getting me motivated to get on my
grind I want you know Melissa is that
that is that actually is the community
we've created here and the community of
people that are not only a part of this
but our at growth video ally right like
when you this is just a glimpse of what
it looks like to be a part of this full
community go ahead Mel I just had to say
that because it's so important about
what that looks like when you're meeting
new people and the different types of
diversities and channels yes definitely
so really quick before we bring a cat on
I want to ask a question from living
quite simply she's asking do you always
recommend putting 2020 in the video
title when you're doing a versus video
oh such a great question and we
recommend that if it is the newer one
what's great about putting the year is
that you can do an update every single
year so guess what we do here at think
media best camera for YouTube 2019
and then we make another video in 2020
called best camera for YouTube 2020
because what can happen is um let me
know if you've had this before you type
something into YouTube and you look at
it and you're like man that's four years
old I do this all the time Melissa when
it comes to like WordPress stuff or
software things or or yeah like anything
like that where you're where you really
just want to know well what is it for
this year I think it's great to have
relevant conversations and videos that
can last over time but a lot of times
people want the fresh thing they want
the new thing and so by being able to do
verses video 2020 it means hey this is
most relevant this is what it looks like
every year we make the video is it too
late to start a YouTube video in I mean
the YouTube channel is it too late to
start a YouTube channel in we did it in
2017 2018 2019 2020 that's four videos
and every year we add a new nuance right
because the landscape changes we add a
new thing because maybe maybe that that
wasn't something we were really hitting
on at that time but we're able to now
say it in a different new fresh way so
yeah 2020 adding the year is a really
important thing and especially if you're
doing things like he was doing with
software if you're doing anything with
software or with gaming or anything like
that anything that has new updates it's
great to make those videos as they come
out yeah that's awesome and and really
helpful and I see a lot of people
putting their title ideas or the next
video ideas in the chat keep that going
drop your title for your next verses
video in the chat right now and we'll
all be able to give you some input and
share those ideas together so now we're
gonna bring on cat and then cat welcome
to think marketing Q&A show hi go ahead
and tell us a little bit about your
channel oh I'm so excited so to you guys
you guys are both an inspiration it's
just amazing I am I new to YouTube
didn't even used to watch it and then
got laid off due to recent circumstances
and wanted to stay home my son and try
and make money so turn my side hustle
into the YouTube channel I'm yet to be
brave enough to go
on camera myself but I make custom
pop-up cards and custom gifts and things
and I was doing that I went to market
and then obviously the markets were
closed so I just got my hundred
subscribers yesterday no this morning it
was a good milestone and I'm just
curious um you know if my channel is on
family if my channel is on track if you
know I've kind of tried to create things
I've learnt from you guys when you did
the women workshop and stuff trying to
create my thumbnails uniform I've
recently added playlists I recently had
a two buddy yesterday I'm trying to
figure it all out and unloving learning
but it's hard to know if I'm actually on
track and if I'm actually reaching my
audience and if I was to do a versus
video what would I do versus oh because
I have so many different things that I
kind of make this all handmade custom so
open to ideas yes first I just want to
congratulate you you know think about
this I think sometimes we think like
these big numbers like I was saying
earlier are like the whole and of course
we do want a great gained influence but
think about this like 20 people
subscribing to your channel it's filling
a classroom that every time you put a
video out there watching a hundred
people that's we're filling half an
auditorium like when you think about
like the actual impact of those numbers
so first care I just want to
congratulate you for what you're doing
you're putting content out there you
flip the script right you like you're
like I need to learn from the new I'm
gonna go into this and you see the
vision and I just want to first say like
congratulations on getting started
because so many people right now are
watching you cat and they're saying wow
look at her she's doing it yes yes but
you're just figuring it all out so
here's a couple things one I think your
channel direction and clarity make sense
me Melissa it makes sense you right
she's making handmade things yes so when
you think about versus videos one of the
things that people that want to do what
you're doing
like with making those handmade things
are the actual materials that you use
okay I was coaching on someone that's
inside of our video ranking Academy one
of our students is an artist and she
does watercolors and for her she was
like I mean what do I like this water
colors versus this water colors and I
said yes people want to know too you
you're so close to it you're an expert
already and so you're so close to it I
see like paper behind you all right I
see that like I see all this stuff
behind you and I'm like I wouldn't even
know what to buy when I exactly so like
if you're like this at he adhesive
versus this adhesive because I've used
this one and it's all the things all of
the organization thinks you have behind
you that is a video because you're
talking about you know what to say
organized to know what paper you need I
like this cutter versus this cutter like
that's the kind of videos that you'd be
making itself will they get millions of
views probably not but that's not the
point the point is cat is we need a
thousand true fans that's what we're
shooting for a thousand true fans why a
thousand well there's a study that was
out there that said if you had a
thousand true fans and you were to sell
something to those fans you could make a
hundred thousand dollars you could make
five hundred thousand dollars you could
make a million dollars if you have
thousand true fans will make sure to
post that in the chat a thousand true
fans study but what's amazing about that
is that you're building a community of
crafters just like you and so when you
think about what verses videos do I do
or how do I make money off of this you
can sell your products actually there's
a video I want to make sure you watch
it's like we did it on think media we
interviewed our friend Angie Lee and she
talked about different side health you
can do just what you're currently doing
cat you could sell your art right that's
the big one you could start a community
where you teach people but you give them
lessons art lessons so you could
actually just start art lessons right
now on udemy or on on a kids are staying
home right there's so many things you
could do that way and then affiliate
marketing you can sign up with not only
just Amazon but there's other store
- like Hobby Lobby jo-ann's fabric
Michaels Target Walmart all of those
places also have affiliate programs that
you could do as well so you need you can
grow that is through those different
channels do you need to have a minimum
subscribers and followers really great
question here's what they want they want
to make sure you're a real person they
don't want a bot because people will
scam their services and they don't do
that it's not actually based on
subscribers it's based on clarity of
your products it's based on clarity of
what you're doing so I was able as a
homeschool mom to get approved with one
video because I just said I'm a
homeschool mom I'm selling these type of
products these are the types of videos
I'm gonna create and they were able to
see the the people I don't even know who
does the approvals because each one's
different
um but you you don't have to have a
certain amount of subscribers or a
certain amount of viewers when you're
doing affiliate marketing you do when
you're trying to actually get ad revenue
from your videos so you do need to have
a certain benchmark which I think it I
don't want to misquote it so someone can
look it up for me and put it in the chat
cuz I don't remember what the number is
right now but it's a certain number to
get those YouTube ads but for affiliate
marketing you don't and here's the thing
you can apply more than one time and
don't let that hold you back from making
those videos because guess what you can
do you can just go back you can you want
to help your audience so help them and
make those videos and just send them to
Amazon and then if you get a proof for
Amazon go back to those videos you got
your tea sit next to you go into those
videos you just change out the links and
now you're in business so I want you to
just be encouraged that it's not a
number it's about the clarity that you
have in your products thank you awesome
thank you so much Kat for being on the
show today and I just want to encourage
you that you're doing it and so stay
connected with us have you watched our
free masterclass yet yes yeah no I was
with you guys for the free week training
thing as well you did the whole YouTube
challenge as well yeah I saved a lot of
it because I couldn't
do it in the moment because I said for
you but it was amazing and just just
learning and having you guys inspire me
in that way it's scary especially to get
on camera yeah I can't believe I'm even
doing this now
yeah it's keeps me going forward you
know and the hundred subscribers like
yeah I'm gonna get out there today and
talk to you so thank you so much thank
you so much Kat for being on today yeah
and uh yeah just want to say one more
word for cat really quickly as I know
you're saying that you're scared to get
on camera and I feel you so like so much
I hate being on camera to be perfectly
honest and I am still working up the
like and like the energy and the
comfortable like feeling of comfort of
being on camera and you have an awesome
energy and you're just you have like
this joy that's like rating eight
radiating out of you and I think that if
you've been scared to get on camera you
should jump on camera and you should be
in front of the camera and I know you're
doing crafting videos but you know you
have an energy that's gonna attract
people and that's gonna bless people so
I just want to encourage you it with
that as well alright so next up we have
Nancy and we can bring Nancy on screen
hi Nancy okay tell us a little bit about
you and your channel okay so I'm an
engineer and my niece is super specific
I help people with a process called
reliability-centered maintenance so I
help them figure out how to take care of
their machines with maintenance programs
and other things and so I only have 315
subscribers so I want to get more and my
specific question is what do you think
about making multiple versus videos and
if so making a playlist out of it that's
good Mel why don't you take this one
yeah so I definitely think that there is
power in doing multiple versus video
like if you find something that works
for you like let's let's double down on
that and we have to think about your
videos as they're attracting new people
and as they're serving your current
subscribers and so when you
are looking at okay this product versus
this product then this product versus
this product if somebody came in to your
world in one of those videos the chances
are that they're going to like to see
more of that content and so doubling
down on what is working and if that
style of video is working 100% and I'm
not super familiar with your industry or
which kinds of videos you're making but
I can definitely see as heather was
mentioning you being able to do a lot of
different types of topics as well maybe
it's specific software's or maybe it's
specific techniques I'm not sure exactly
what it is but you can do different
types of different types of versus
videos that are not just all the
different kinds of products and then
also those videos are going to be really
effective for bringing in new people as
well and then putting them all into one
playlist like absolutely create a
playlist that has to do with you know
this one specific type of question and
maybe has some of your verses in it
create a playlist that has all the
verses videos in it that's totally fine
to experiment with that yeah and I want
to point you over here here's a really
good playlist strategy so when you're
over on your actual site as I move this
little thing over all the way on your
home page here is a hack that most
people don't do when you're doing your
actual playlists which we have one here
you actually want to title it this the
way you would title a YouTube video so
don't just put like playlist one or like
mechanics one it would be literally what
is that playlist about and actually
playlists can come in a can can come up
as ranked things in search as well so so
you want to be thinking about doubling
down on the playlist strategy itself
which is titling it like a YouTube video
or thinking about how would someone type
this in what is the pain point that
would get them to need to watch these
ten videos and what I like about
playlists too is you can create multiple
playlists and a video doesn't just have
to be in one playlist so with that video
could live in four different playlists
if you want it to be in different things
based on what the search ability of that
is that makes sense yeah
yes awesome and hey I just want to
congratulate you you said you're already
at 300 subscribers yeah 3:15 and am I
correct that you can't go live just on
YouTube without using streaming out or
something like that do you have to still
have a thousand subscribers I think the
threshold is a thousand subscribers um
to be able to go live I think and now
don't quote me on that because I know I
don't look I didn't look into that but a
thousand subscribers is a great goal to
get to and what you can do is you can um
you can always live stream into like you
can live stream into Facebook you can
live stream on Instagram if you have
LinkedIn live you could do that too so
like there's other places you can go
live but getting to that threshold is is
important to get you to the next step
okay thank you so much Nancy for joining
us today
Thank You babies I need to look into
that Mel I'm pretty sure it is a
thousand subscribers for that to get the
live Tony you can give me a thumbs up if
you know if it's a thousand subscribers
or someone in our community can look it
up
yep tony says 1k to stream on mobile
interesting I wonder Tony is it 1k to
stream on non mobile what it's not
mobile check that link ok Tony's got a
link for Heather to put in here and we
can we can look it up but Melissa how
cool is that don't you just love the
diversity of channels that are online
absolutely yeah it's so cool to see what
you can do with YouTube and I've
actually seen full like full courses
like from colleges on YouTube and you
can also see you know the crafting
channels and there's just this huge
variety and it really shows that you can
do so much with this free platform and
that's just the craziest part about it
that anybody can post videos on there so
speaking of diversity and in channel
we're gonna bring on our next person and
see what they do
so presto I'm really curious to see
presto what your channel is hey guys
yeah I I started this do you hear me you
got me yeah ok so I started this YouTube
challenge with you guys was on the fence
with it but as you can imagine being a
magician in this ko bid situation I lost
all my gigs overnight and it is slowly
trickling back in right now but it's a
long way to go so I wanted to prepare
myself for the next recession by
starting this YouTube channel so I do
magic for beginners so I'm not sure
quite Heather how to do a versus with
something like that I'm looking for any
tips or advice you guys can give me I'm
new to this by the way I only got 63
well I sixty-three subscribers that's
amazing though I mean can we celebrate
the small wins to think marketing cuz it
is so important okay
so I I just I just typed this in I typed
in magic for beginners um and I'm sure
you're already looking at these don't be
intimidated by channels with 7 million
subscribers and 4 million subscribe
don't be intimidated by that okay
because you are your own magician too
right like everyone's different they
have their different ways so um what
would be like a card tricks versus um
magic tricks I don't know I'm just
trying to think of different things you
can just type in you can type in
different verses videos or it could be
like the is there certain um magic sets
that people want to buy their kids or is
there certain right like I'm thinking
products like if I were to get into
magic I would have no clue what to buy
so if you're doing magic for beginners
is there a magic set that you recommend
they get like it's on Amazon or
something I actually have my own okay
that's even better so that's it yeah so
you can do so so I want you to think
outside the box okay so I want you to
think about what are the things this is
this for everyone so lean in what are
the things that people need to buy in
order to do the thing that I teach okay
so what is their books about it is their
products around it is their software
around it is their online classes around
it right so there's a lot of different
things that people could buy and you can
do that
or especially in magic I'm sure there's
like this trick versus that trick which
one's easier or something like that like
you could even just think about the
different nuances of what you're doing
so versus strategy is just one strategy
that we teach here at think media so I I
know you said you started with us inside
of the YouTube influence challenge which
I'm really excited about I want you to
dive in more and more into what we're
teaching inside of inside of think media
when it comes to the types of videos to
create versus is just one strategy but
there's so many things you could be
doing I love this like some what this
guy did three easy card tricks you can
learn in five minutes so thinking about
things the amount of time it takes
someone to do something the the
behind-the-scenes of setting it up I
mean there's so many ways that you can
do it and you can create your own online
course teaching people so I want you to
think that taking things that you are
doing offline and bringing it online
you've got time so if the next step for
you is to create your Buy button right
what's your online offer what's your
online Buy button
it could be a magic for beginners and
it's twenty seven dollars or ninety
seven dollars and it walks you through
all of the steps that you could do I
bought one for my kids because my son
was getting into magic I didn't know
what to buy I was like magic for a
beginner he's like I was like magic for
kids and which to me even speaks
differently than magic for beginners so
also just be thinking of the nuances of
the words that you're using and the
target that you're trying to hit Melissa
any advice for him yeah I would say as
far as like other ideas there was some
ideas in the chat so definitely go back
and look at those tony was saying
illusionist versus magician and I was
thinking when you first said that I was
thinking like your different techniques
there's different techniques for doing
different tricks so like this technique
versus this technique or this like
Heather was mentioning like going for
the product route because that'll also
help with affiliate sales or help with
your product sales and you can do you
know this type of card to this card deck
like I know that there's huge
differences and I'm not sure what kind
of magician you are yeah exactly
I do I do a lot of close-up stuff so
it's a lot of cards and coins and
different things like that and my name
is preparing for the Christmas season is
to have my magic kits and magic wands
and all this other stuff available for
the public but I only have three videos
out so I'm trying to build my tribe a
little bit before I go doing affiliates
and all that other stuff because I don't
have enough following just yet but I'm
applying everything I've learned from
you guys so yeah I think that's awesome
and I definitely think we talked a lot
about also like writing trends and I
know like this in this community there
are a lot of like big names or there'll
be big shows that are going on there
people are coming so you can maybe look
at you know this person versus this
person and looking at analyzing their
techniques and their style or and you
know in just in general and then
obviously you don't have to just do
verses videos but I can see a lot of
different a lot of different avenues
that you can take since you're just
starting and I think it's a really
exciting industry at the ends okay you
thinks all that stuff isn't in the plans
too it's just a lot going on up here so
yes it'll happen
so awesome well thank you so much for
being on and Melissa I think it's so
cool when we have beginners on we have
people who who you know are further
along but today's episode really felt
like it was those under a thousand
subscribers and I really want to just
encourage you that if you are under a
thousand subscribers keep going keep
making those videos and you maybe two
videos or five videos or 30 videos in
and this is a long gameplay you're not
just starting YouTube to just make a
couple videos you're in business and
just like any business if you were to
open a coffee shop right now you would
do the work right you would get out
there you would be putting in the hours
to make this happen I want you to think
about your YouTube channel as your
business and usually they say right
Melissa it takes three to five years to
actually see like actual profits out of
that with YouTube you can go so much
faster and I just want to encourage you
that every video you put out there get
1% better you're doing this it's a
process it's hard work but every video
you put out will get you one step closer
to the ankle and I'm just excited to see
all those different channels that were
on today yes and I will be so excited to
see so many
you guys September 8 to 10 that Gorillaz
video live we get to dive in to all of
these different topics to meet so many
amazing people during that time so it's
gonna be in a virtual experience but by
no means will that mean that it's
limited in terms of community and
connection and networking so that's
gonna just be an awesome time to get to
see you guys and have even more even
more time together it just makes us all
feel I I genuinely from the events we've
had it I leave feeling like we're a
family it sounds so cheesy but it's so
true like you just get really close to
people when you're spending that much
time together talking in chat and
learning the same kinds of things so I
hopefully will get to see a lot of you
guys there yes and you can get your
tickets right now at groweth video
live.com this episode this u Q&A episode
was brought to you by growth video lives
make sure you head over there grab your
tickets I'm telling you you do not want
to miss this you will have so much fun
oh when you see it on social media if
you don't get to this year's growth
video live there's a couple different
options for packages you can purchase to
get some more intimate time but I'm
telling you that this is the place you
need to be if you know you want to grow
on YouTube this year and beyond thank
you so much for being on the thinker
marketing Q&A and we will catch you on
the next show bye